ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo video sono fa vj non ci siamo su
the visitor che c'è in genere mi
aspettavo un videogioco con un menù con
qualcosa da cisco me la scritta tipo
deve esito un cazzo proprio che
logicamente niente iniziamo
cioè siamo già lì nel mezzo non so che
farò non so come banana vabbè inizia
cos'è sta cosa meteorite una rana
bellissimo a sei una figata la madonna
ascoltami zio che sono fare qui
accennavamo scassato tutto ciò dovrebbe
essere un gioco in flash solo che devo
perché cosa se clicca qua si gira il
piccione
[Musica]
i ragazzi vabbè apporta il piccione che
si muove a lo faccio cascare qual è
l'obiettivo dove tre qua dentro in casa
c'è posso trascinare delle cose cos'è
arva bello c'è una cosa posso adesso la
rana se la mangia lo sapevo ok che bello
questo gioco non mi piaceva già
dall'inizio e ve lo dico c'è veramente
lo devo fare delle cose in modo da
andare avanti ma un casino perché
distrutto il tronco al cosa devo quale
in qual è il mio obiettivo ora c'è un
pesce adesso il pesce è nato qua sotto
non aspetta per il cazzo clicco adesso
la canna pesca e ho capito fermi un
attimo perfette arriva il pesce canna da
pesca disastro mica è un casino sto
gioco per noi cosa ok pesca sta merda
certo ovvio in qualcuno mi spiega che
cosa cazzo sto giocando cioè erano
illuminati
[Musica]
sta roba è significativa ragazzi
comunque perché mi sono schiantato su
una finestra e ho visto tra horror e
nonsense sto gioco cosa cazzo fatto ho
mangiato una mela o ubicato su una
pianta certo adesso arrivato un ragno
c'è il gatto che si mangia il ragno cosa
cazzo sta succedendo regata c'è ma è il
senso di questo no seriamente cosa cazzo
clicco cosa devo fare
cioè è una roba indecente no merda ma
visto e vabbè entra nel buco per te come
faccia visto l'ha relegato ragazzi
niente deve picchiare ma non tua madre
felina l'ammazzo giuro cos'è certo ma
ovvio ma che cosa ma perché migliaia più
platform odiato ma perché questo verme
c'è ancora lo devo capire ragazzi
comunque devo andare dove vado
sono uscito scommetto la vita che devo
cliccare il buco del culo del gatto ma
ci scommetto che volete
ecco schifo cos'è va bene raga ok
permesso possiamo entrare nella pace sta
diventando sapere il grande tra l'altro
e roero piccolo così all'inizio sto
crescendo me non so cosa salve devo
mangiare anche le prime che l'obiettivo
e mangiare degli esseri viventi per
diventare più grosso mezzo chiudi cioè
io apro i cassetti questa leader che
trojan svoltasi a lo sai contro chi ti
stai mettendo io prendo i coltelli dal
nulla ma io faccio le cose le e lei mi
corre ma mi prende per il culo con un
ragazzo il frullatore
ma chi è che sta facendo se cose che non
sto capendo le arance perché della
lancia sì sto facendo il frullato che
vigoda ziativa un frullato di arance
aranciata che sia veloce compro la corda
di visto poi che la infilo tu sai dove
sappino il cane mi caccia a uno sguardo
che è il numero 1 cazzo fatemi capire il
senso che solo cliccare il cane kaikan e
incassa il cane in casa tong coltello no
cassetti no
devo criticare il fiore in fiore non
lezione allora chi cazzo vuoi apri addio
o distratta ragazzi lo distrae adesso
devo applica set e massei trai allora
devo fare qualcosa mentre distratta di
sicuro so che non ho capito cosa gli
altri piatti di sportelli cosa ha
allagato tutto fantastico mogli ciampa
lo sapevo minchia un atleta come cazzo
ha fatto a tassi così primo sta roba
il lavandino veloce e catto bravo
adesso devo anche il cassetto si è
svenuta eh va beh
sei una stronza di merda [ __ ] tante
cose devo fare in un secondo fatto in
capire allora frolla apri allaga come i
cessi a scuola e da piccolo l'ho fatto
una volta mai adesso vieni coltello a
non soggetti ad esso non si rialza
secondo me non ne sono sicuro però è la
zia ci siamo allora adesso possiamo
muoverci liberamente
ho commesso un omicidio incredibile si
possono andare perfetto per vento sempre
questa cosa non lo so ma la clicco
perché sono un figo si aperto ragazzi si
aperto il coni giamaicane rimasto lì in
tutto questo non ha fatto un cazzo
va bene il cane dei miei [ __ ] dove
vado cosa click è il ninja della madonna
e ragazzi sono avanti entra nel in cane
secondo me non deve entrare nel con voto
a me fottiamo cioè del cane hachi caso
sono questi ci sono due tipi e io sono
nel condotto sicuro perfetto giornata di
piccione di nuovo il piccione di prima
ascolta zio devo entrare negli anni devo
io devo diventare sempre più grosso caso
sono molto più figo di prima deve
entrare nel piceno
qual è l'obiettivo di sta cosa ceco
scusando vedevo arrivare quando finisce
questo gioco mi sta mettendo un asse
incredibile dove vado sono intanto mezzo
pesce adesso de posso mangiare le mangi
meno
a tutti vestiti sono nato adesso mi
mangio piccione ovvio è tornata ragazzon
diventate una cosa incredibile che figo
mica come più ma va bene è na figata
soggiogarla il dogma ho fatto ma
scoprirlo prima è bellissimo
guarda fratello adesso mi sono mangiata
la donna bellissima osso diventato una
cosa bella che per gli occhi dolci
trattazione mangia
no non ci credo che schifo va bene
gadget schifo sta diventato una rana non
lo so perché mi sono mangiato un uomo
sono evitato una rana perfetto è bene
che cos'è la sua faccia ragazzi ora la
pace e bellissima promesse cagato
addosso quando sentite che si muove
qualcosa che non capite che cos'è
in realtà sono io va beh
è la madonna che cos'è intanto qui a
questo si è retta
ok ragazzi created by tim burton finito
beh gioco dell'anno per i play l'ass
voglio vedere tutta la l'ultima scena
che non lo capisce che c'è questo
nascosto nel cesso che ha sentito le
urla poi arrivò davanti perché ma perché
va bene basta così
è stato bello ma veramente bello che
vedete i ragazzi concluso vi è bisogno
spero che vino vi sia piaciuto ma solito
se credete che questi siano animali
domestici belli e se volete adottarlo
fatemelo sapere
ebi vengo a trovare sotto il letto con
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto come al
solito al suo documento di piace al
capace di facebook e come vi adottata
nella sezione se volete capire che cosa
si è fumato ziba wrf prima di fare
questo gioco
ve lo dirò io non adesso però e noi ci
vediamo un prossimo video e lo ragazzi